[Music]
foreign
the loss of us is a great TV show and it
is an adaptation of the famous video
game of the same name so in this
post-apocalyptic world most of humanity
is either dead surviving in quarantined
zones like isolated warring tribes or
they have been turned into zombie-like
creatures or Monsters but the best thing
about this kind of infection is that it
differs from the norm While most
storylines focus on viruses that turn
humans into zombies here it is a species
of fungi that does the trick
let's take a look at its Origins first
from the games and then what is told to
us in the series
well in the game across late September
2013 a mutant strain of the goddess of
fungus began to spread in the United
States beginning from Texas and
gradually all over the country this
species of human infecting cordyceps the
name of the fungi originated in South
America where it mutated to spread to
humans via diseased crops then it began
to spread all over Latin America and
gradually into the Southern State
starting from Texas and eventually the
entire world
in the series however in the second
episode the earliest incidents was
recorded in Jakarta in Indonesia in
September the 3rd of the year 2003. a
Mycologist named ratna was called to
examine a human corpse and she was
stunned to find out a living moving
chordiceps infestation inside the body
of a person working in a grain Factory
and immediately was briefed that this
spread has started to occur with at
least 14 suspected of being infected to
which she gave no other advice on how to
contain the situation or cure it and the
only advice was to bomb the City's
population in order to stop the spread
so after 23 days since the discovery in
Indonesia and the following outbreak in
that country as well as neighboring
Asian countries the epidemic eventually
reached the United States on September
26 2003. this is known as outbreak day
and ambulances roared across Austin
Texas giving the first hints of the
problem the epidemic hits critical mass
in the early hours of September 27th and
the streets became chaotic planes crash
everywhere and military personnel began
to obstruct highways leading out of the
city of Austin this led to chaos and an
iron fist martial law which didn't
really solve anything but led to the
eventual creation of settlements and the
quarantine zones across the U.S for
survivors
now what is this species of fungi in the
series and what is the real life version
well in a series it is commonly only
referred to as cordyceps it's Gina's
name however was actually ophio
cordyceps with no species name ever
stated the real-life version of your
cordyceps unilateralis has a terrifying
yet beautiful life cycle ants are
infected when they come into touch with
spores on the forest floor the fungus
enters the ant's body and begins to
multiply it sells in certain areas such
as the brain and the muscle area and
release a certain chemical molecules to
influence the ants Behavior the fungi
takes over the motor functions of the
insect and the Ant is taught to bite
into the underside of a leaf high above
the ground having Optimum temperature
and sunlight for the fungus to develop
because of certain chemicals its mouth
latches onto the leaf and stays there
until the fruiting body emerges from its
head it eventually breaks open releasing
additional spores over the forest floor
infecting no ants
so how did it evolve and what does the
show tell us about it well going back to
the beginning of the first episode to
the scene of a TV interview in 1968 a
certain epidemiologist Dr Newman states
that he is not concerned about germs
bacteria or viruses causing a pandemic
rather that fungi are his worst fear
mostly because they take over the host
rather than simply killing it scientists
have long bonded why insects plants and
amphibians are particularly sensitive to
fungal infections according to research
controlling body temperature or
homeothermy is an effective barrier
against fungal infection fungi flourish
in Cola settings which makes them
effective adversaries of insects
amphibians and plants with us humans our
hot body temperature is a fatal factor
to them
so as Dr Newman describes about a warmer
planet and a false evolutionary jump in
the case of these fungi certain species
might develop a resistance to high body
temperature of humans and other animals
and eventually be able to cause a global
spread taking over people's minds like
puppets with the main goal of
propagating the species to every corner
of the globe so in this case it was not
a ringworm or a Canada yeast infection
that evolved but a deadly ophio
cordyceps that made a hyper leap in
evolutionary terms to not only infecting
humans but also developing a hyper fast
growth rate as well as maintaining a
mycelium Network in the ground for
communications like the Trees of Avatar
the fungi after infecting a human Takes
Over Control of the body turning it into
a zombie in a few hours and then
gradually mutates the person into a
deadly monster which over time further
develops and mutates into even more
deadlier monsters that we will talk
about in another video
so the evolution of such a pathogen that
takes over the minds and controls and
changes the morphology of the body is so
extreme that it would not really occur
in real life in a short timeline the
process would be slow like making a jump
from an insect into a vertebrate like an
amphibian then from that to a snake then
to a bird and gradually to small rodents
and then to humans and then the rate of
growth would be really slow as we are
larger organisms with a robust immune
system and not to mention the
anti-fungal creams at our disposal but
it could be genetically engineered in a
mycology lab like I don't know maybe the
previous pathogen that made us all wear
diapers on our chins
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos here on this channel till the
next one take care fam